eigentlich sollte es für die 23-jährige
der glücklichste tag ihres lebens werden
sie hat ihren ersten ausbildungstag
zusammen mit 40 damit sogar 50 jungen
männern und frauen
und die waren alle aufgeregt hatten sich
schick gemacht und dann gab es eine
kurze begrüßung im rathaus und dann
sollten alle zum obligatorischen
gruppenfoto auf den rathausplatz
rauskommen alle waren aufgeregt
ausgelassen stellten sich zusammen und
dann an das ganze unglück seinen lauf
ein lkw fahrer hatte beim rückwärts
rangieren einen fahnenmast übersehen
fuhr rückwärts rein da brach ab und dann
die 23 jährige die nicht mehr ausweichen
konnte und der notarzt konnte nichts
anderes mehr machen außerdem tour
festzustellen hieß oberbürgermeister und
kämpfer war gestern auch bei diesem
tragischen unfall dabei wird er sich
danach dazu geäußert wenn man natürlich
gestürzte waren selbst er sagte dass es
ihm schwer fallen würde die richtigen
worte zu finden
es wurden blumen hier hinter mir
abgelegt die ganzen fans vor dem rathaus
sind auf halbmast
man merkt die ganze stadt wird sauer
auch die anderen 49 azubis mussten das
mit ansehen wie geht es ihnen jetzt wie
werden sie betreut
es waren andere krisen helfer vor ort
ich hatte mit einem mit azubis schon
kurz kontakte sagte er konnte nur das
große lächeln der 23 jährigen sehen dann
ging alles ganz schnell
und er seien auch zu mitgenommen und
auch zu erschüttert um dir etwas dazu
sagen zu können
zu der familie hat man noch keinen
kontakt das war gestern schwierig für
die polizei die angehörigen direkt
ausfindig zu machen deswegen wurden die
sehr spitz über das ganze tragische
geschehen informiert und jetzt liegt das
ganze bei der kriminalpolizei und die
staatsanwaltschaft jetzt gegen den lkw
fahrer wegen fahrlässiger tötung
ermittelt wird